yeah you going on Gregg elbow I'm Gerry
I mean I'm John that's who I am I'm
doing the opening all right dude we're
doing the opening do it again hey guys
I'm Greg Alba and I'm John yes good so
we saw the movie the nice guys people
and I can tell you this it was more than
just a nice time yeah it was a great
time
you could ask John guys ask him right
now we were watching the movie rep
before so I'm like I don't want to go to
the theaters but we went and I did not
regret it at all it was a delightful
film in so many ways John how did you
feel about it
yeah I'm right there with you I sort of
swept away by this movie and when we
were going in like I wasn't super
psyched because you know like the
advertising never quite grabbed me and
so the viral videos never quite grabbed
me but once we got into the theater it
was like the kind of movie they don't
make anymore it felt like a real movie
like it felt like an older sort of
timeless movie and it had so much
personality yeah like for my friends who
are into film I make sure to use the
word film when I'm around them like guys
this is a legit film everything about it
is just damn good movie making but the
big obvious ones that we all sort of saw
coming
Russell Crowe and Ryan Gosling have
dynamic chemistry together and it was
exactly what I wanted when I saw the
trailer like okay I want this to be a
funny movie I also still want some great
characters out of these two because
they're known to be character actors oh
yeah well this whole thing is about
characters man yeah this thing's full of
personality you know Russell Crowe is
great in the role I like seeing you know
overweight Russell Crowe I feel like I
can play one of those roles one Dex he
just has this like natural demeanor now
body presence is like yeah he's rough
tough you don't want to mess with him
what does I want to see him back in that
kind of mode because this is a film noir
and stuff so I was flashing back it's
like LA Confidential yeah which weirdly
Kim Basinger Zin this - yeah that's true
and then maybe that's intentional and
Russell Crowe you know it's like yeah he
has gained some weight but when he
starts kick
some ass like believe yeah like yeah I
would not want to miss this yeah it's
really believable the Ryan Gosling I
thought did a really good job he took a
character that he's really down on his
luck
really depressed he's an alcoholic
smoked cigarettes all [ __ ] day long
he's someone who like can be perceived
as rather as kind of a loser he's a
low-life and a [ __ ] he out of ways but
then you get so many Mosher like but
he's a great detective yeah when he
really rises to the occasion when the
circumstances come together and he
really just has to rise to the occasion
he actually is very sharp at what he
does and that's kind of the fun is like
seeing how these guys kind of both are
where they are it was a really natural
buddy-cop yeah it wasn't just like ah
you're loose and you play by the rules
this was like these guys have two
different sets of qualities that when
they put them together it works you know
what I liked about what they especially
what they did with Ryan Gosling was he
has like these serious character issues
like this character has some serious
things he's dealing with every time
Laura was scared for they just bring him
not because they don't like a gun or
anything which like scared because yeah
especially when he gets drunk what I
love about that was they didn't
emphasize it too much to the point where
it starts you know slowing down the film
that it starts becoming like this
dramatic dark thing and like oh we
really want him to cut out drinking and
stuff oh yeah it doesn't make that the
point it never it's not a subplot it's
like you can tell it's happening enough
so that we can go yeah it doesn't take
time to stop and go hey alcoholism is
really bad I just think their chemistry
in the film was so natural like when you
when you look at how they start off and
then how they end up becoming really
good you know really close with each
other it's done in a way that's just so
not cliche like there's no scene where
you're like hey you're right you're
right - buddy what makes these
characters so Cuban is you get the sense
that they're all having other stuff
going on in their life while they're
working on the mystery yeah a lot of big
Hollywood movies is just like their life
is the mystery both of them have things
going on that affect their characters
and so like they're in worse and worse
shape as like the mystery gets crazier
and crazier yeah and it just makes yeah
everybody seemed more like a fleshed out
person totally totally to the credit of
Shane blacks writing I know
we didn't get a chance to finish kiss
kiss man man when I was showing it to
you but I love kiss kiss maiming and I
am like one of the few people on the
internet who is willing to admit he
really liked soccer man 3-chain black's
directing I feel like is more solid than
ever he really does bring the seventies
to life it was like a film that was shot
in the seventies okay no it's not like a
flashy 70s film like trying to really
make the 70s pop like it's yes there
that's the time you know oh yes they
borrowed from like the way they would
shoot or edit things yeah different
kinds of shots and different ways to
approach editing and then there were
certain moments that would come in that
would just like really interesting
angles every now and again her he would
slip you in to like a more slapstick
chorus you know surreal sequence he's
really painting with the direction here
I just think the script is is is
brilliant there's witty dialogue for
sure it's clever the the plot twists and
turns you know they're the right right
amount of like heartfelt character
moments yeah are there everything was it
was it was a funny entertaining film
where it never got too carried away in
its comedy yeah yeah it kept everything
just at the right level well yeah and
and sometimes it flirts with the lion
but it always lands just inside of it
like the bathroom scene that's all live
in a trailer like it's almost too big
but but it's not quite you know yeah
it's just right shame black man he's the
best that buddy-cop it seems like yeah
he is the best at doing that well this
whole world in this movie is populated
with like a lot of great supporting
characters too and like everyone is
specific and the actors they got to play
the moon from the recognizable people
like Keith David there's somebody who's
great character actors and all the other
supporting roles and stuff like that
angry Russia plays Holly Ryan Gosling's
daughter it and I said this in my
trailer review and no one else has
pointed this out in their trailer review
this guy knows his trailers I was saying
like I'm really looking forward to
seeing the dynamics that play between
Ryan Gosling and the person playing his
daughter yeah I feel like that's gonna
play an integral parts in the movie that
could actually work you know seeing
Gosling really playing a dad I know in
real life he is a dad but this does show
Ryan Gosling as an older carrot
you do buy him as a father like
instantly you don't there's no question
like you don't have a hard time
adjusting to Ryan Gosling being a dad it
requires some chops for him to get this
role you know together but he certainly
nails it it's not like Oh almost because
the daughter in the film too is a bit
older like you know he's he's kind of a
young parent you would get the sense but
he sells that and he sells that you know
along with being this lowlife private
investigator and this sort of cowardly
guy that's the best parent but he
clearly loves his daughter
yeah Lilly cares he's clearly trying
that's all so dysfunctional yeah I
really like the girl I thought the girl
was great like she wasn't some child
actor from like ah she's so acting or
whatever yeah like she seemed really
natural with everything she had to do
yeah there's a very sincere performance
it was a really well-written character
too I really liked her and I feel like
sometimes that kind of character tend to
be like can be kind of annoying
let her though I thought she was smart
she was clever if she was never too
smart to the poem like a quarter it just
couldn't do that you could see a really
intelligent smart girl of that age
pulling off things that she was doing
yeah and it fits in with the world that
this movie has around it cuz everything
is kind of quirky she brings a lot just
to the dynamic and I really enjoyed that
partly because like that's part of the
diversity of this movie I feel like is
there's so many different kinds of
characters and everyone's kind of
represented in a way that's not super
obvious yeah and there's a lot of like
clever subtext hidden in the dialogue
where people are just discussing
attitudes that are you know kind of in
the cultural space right now issues of
like you know masculinity and femininity
and age and and you know all kinds of
things you know classes and stuff
because that's where it takes place and
how yeah it's very clever very clever
it's a film in the 70s it also reflects
on today I just don't get films like
this anymore and it's more than a
throwback vibe like for sure it's more
than trying that it's not yeah it's not
it's not just a film where this guy
likes these kind of movies so he wants
to resurrect it like yeah it's it he's
telling his own story you know it's Jay
I know it's based on a book but he is go
you could tell that Shane black made
this his own what it feels like a film
noir novel oh yeah noir novel because it
is recreating an older time I thought it
was cool just the little flourishes like
a lot of the establishing shots looked
like stock footage yeah you know shot in
an older
for a way so it wasn't like look at we
recreated every yeah sort like this slip
things in part of the great subtlety of
the direction here is like sometimes
it's really big but other times it'll
slip stuff in where you're like oh neat
and also the balance of tones - because
it's like cool sometimes it's gritty
sometimes it's like funny cuz it's
awkward sometimes it's slapstick
sometimes it's surreal or fantastical
like he brings a lot of stuff in here
and it's all really cool you know it
always it all makes for a really nice
whole shame black [ __ ] I had to say I'm
sure you didn't come on he's that makes
her a really nice hole and his last name
what no actually you're gonna follow up
isn't it like if he found that black was
his middle name
you're gonna go [ __ ] it's not no mmm
what's the way it works it's the way the
mind works
shame black [ __ ] fill in holes alright
guys well let's we're gonna wrap this up
rating time I give this five Gosling
testicles okay and I give it like a
million Russell Crowe's yeah murder of
Russel Crowes that's our new rating
system listen guys if you're near the
channel um do me a favor and break my
nose doctor subscribe today you're worth
your time yeah John has a show here or
playlists reasons Jarek social media
measured blue mask calm you trying to
pass something mmm-hmm and I want to
give shout out to Ryan Gosling Ryan I
wrote a rap song about you there's a
link in the description box for it I
wrote it many years ago and I mean every
word to this day